aber sind wir realistisch machen wir uns
nichts vor vor allem für die grüne basis
wäre jamaika natürlich eine ganz bittere
pille
wie will man die überzeugen mit linda
und merkel ins bett zu steigen ganz
einfach ich begrüße die beste
motivationstrainerin von ganz köln
mülheim wörter schneider
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so so platte wie überreden wir die
grünen denn jetzt ihre prinzipien zu
opfern
grüne prinzip der war gut
diese partei hat 98/99 unsere ersten
kriegseinsätzen seit 45 mitgetragen
genauso wie alle hartz iv reformen eine
gewisse moralische flexibilität gehört
quasi zur grünen dna bis heute ganz
deutschland diskutiert über fahrverbote
aber der satz mit dem der erste grüne
ministerpräsident in die geschichte
eingehen wird ist
ich nehme daimler es klassiker gekonnt
war
seine autobiografie heißt auch ich kann
doch keinen fiat fahren was passt denn
da bitte nicht zur fdp die grünen wollen
zwar eine vermögenssteuer für
superreiche aber sagen nicht dazu ab
wann man superreich ist versuchen sie
doch mal bitte in einem satz zu
beschreiben was zum teufel die grünen
überhaupt sind kann ich nicht
der chairman kann das auf der einen
seite wertkonservativ nicht
strukturkonservativ scheidende cdu
suchen sie denn von nachhaltigkeit
bewahren der schöpfung es ist liberal
aber nicht wirtschaftsliberal oder neo
liberal sondern es ist bürgerrechtlich
liberal und es ist links aber nicht
links im sinne von der linkspartei im
großen strukturen denken oder links im
sinne von emanzipatorisch
[Applaus]
nee
haben sie das verstanden was die sänger
als links doch nicht im sinne von links
also dass andere links da fliegt jedoch
der dinkel aus der hose
wenn ich sowas höre entschuldigung
wollten sie die grünen nicht eigentlich
motivieren jamaika zu machen ja mach ich
jetzt
grüne macht das jetzt traut euch mal war
es die arme spd die hat sich geopfert in
der groko vier jahre bei routine
häckselmaschine tee sind fertig jetzt
seid ihr dran
vorsicht würde sie brauchen sich die
jamaika-koalition in ihrem lauf halten
weder tom noch kathrin auf grüne er kann
keine rücksicht mehr nehmen auf eure
links versiffte grüne basis an das sind
höchstens noch 45 1 ließ die dann
kreuzberg ihren scheiß fair gehandelten
kaffee verkaufen
ihr seid überhaupt nicht in der position
euch einen partner aussuchen zu können
das ist wie drei uhr morgens in der
disco reste [ __ ] schon mal gehört
keiner möchte mit alexander dobrindt am
kabinettstisch sitzen oder auch nur im
selben raum sein
aber es geht nicht anders
ihr werdet noch mehr prinzipien verraten
und ihr werdet auf drei prozent
abstürzen aber ihr tut es verdammt
nochmal für euer land
der zia samen baum der freiheit muss
gegossen werden mit grünem glut aus nach
jamaika fest verderben
[Applaus]
unser büro von peter steinert